okay yes how about just saying your
whole name so we can make sure we get
everything right and just add porn
Marcel seriously serious Antoine and you
are a physician trick
the kind of field of Medicine do you
practice well a specialized ear nose and
throat conditions tonsillitis ear
infections you need anything above a
clavicle
and you also are in the National Guard
correct how long the concern since 1938
or so Oh
Jess I wonder if I can take you back to
the night that your father came home
about what you have an idea about what
time of the night that was and what you
were doing at the time well I was asleep
for one thing I'm not I want to say was
very early hours it's not a very late
evening a very early morning
and awakened both myself in
and wiped he wake you wake you both up
he had something you want to show us
this apparently was some degree or
something he brought in from the field
at that time it I understand he is
another way to the airbase to deliver
this but he felt this was unusual enough
that he wanted us to see it first before
he delivered to his proper destination
and what happened what happened after he
woke you up well he was as I recall very
excited and again he said I want to show
you something and so I got my housecoat
on did my mother and he had gone to the
car and brought back in some metallic
debris I believe is in applause I know I
don't recall it I walked outside with
them or not but he made it seem like
they 1942 a Buick we had with the Lord
of the stuff
in the back seat in the trunk area at
any rate he brought the material in and
spread it on the kitchen floor and in an
effort to try to piece it together like
a jigsaw puzzle to get some item for
unfortunately there's too much owed to
finely divided
how old were you at the time I left and
when he spread all this material out on
the floor what was your impression about
what this what this material was like
how would you describe it well initially
just looking at what's this all about
you know sleepy Oh Angie but then when
you get down and looking at it it was
the unusual character of a degree and I
want to say it he said something like
this is from a flying saucer but I'm not
sure if he said that but the meaning was
clear at this is something very special
and he wanted us to look in what's your
recollection about what the material
looks like felt like well I could divide
in three major categories think back on
it
there was love thick foil-like material
my shiny aluminum but Bernice tore a
slate gray type of aluminum metal there
was a black plastic type debris like
bakelite which was shattered it was very
brittle material and then there were
fragments of what appeared to be I beams
probably small but the typical high beam
type configuration let's talk a little
bit of that each category for a little
bit of detail if you will let's talk
about first oil like substance what
what's sort of what was the size this
material well I don't recall seeing a
piece that was greater than four six
inches in circumference and around
I don't recall well I tried to test for
being able to tear it or bend it or
anything like that that was very light
and again adult Italian curricula and
there was a lot of that
how thick would you describe this
material well it was about
we're slicker than the usual kitchen
foil
I guess there's a neuro foil out there
for heavy-duty usage here's a story
group and that's approximately in terms
of thickness or any other similarities
to everyday household items that he well
with talaq divorce but I could say that
shine and the pieces of the foil like
substance what shape were them well it
was shredded knowledge today I'm torn so
irregular irregular and there was a lot
of this material
well dr. Kovac before was this head war
because there's a lot more that's what's
going to ask he didn't bring it all over
wasn't proportionately okay
oh the the weight of this material you
described as light would you would you
say that it was unusually wide wider
than you would expect or heavier or
anything anything at all unusual about
its weight will further very very very
much in other words you can take piece
and then when just fall before it got
drift down personally that's very
interesting
did you actually see that I no I did not
but this is what you know I thought they
like lions offend the wood you described
as the almost plastic or bakelite like
material tell me a little more about
that well as a black brown in color
again they're regular pieces
about 1/16 of an inch beta globin
greater in thickness and brutal ways our
suspect was brittle pretty shattered
I'm going to make sure I'm staying you
didn't actually see it shattered but it
could appear to have been shattered
I didn't try to bend or test any of
these things so I just picked about
gently and handled anything else unusual
with about the way to this material my
stay was very light also I just kind of
worked it boys
comparing with other anything else
worthy of comment about this material
you were called basically just the
description of color shatter type big
light maturing
and how about what you described is I
beans looking for those life well they
were again looked like a same time
material at the oil light material man
metallic dull gray a woman to bury light
again I did not try to bend it or stress
it in any way all over the piece I
remember looking it was about 12 to 18
inches in length both ends think were
shattered or broken off was not a clean
cut and the material thickness appeared
to be about a sixteenth of an inch and
with color would again so that gray like
a flat balloon attention
metallic hotel definitely the tail
anything else unusual about this
particular piece of material well the
most unusual for this whole thing - what
was going to be I being the inner
surface of an i-beam
because as you look at it at home there
appeared to be a type of writing in the
mainframe itself
this writing was definitely a purplish
violet here
it involves peers because he could burp
all you can really feel anything to tell
if it had texture in or calling singing
lines or letters in kind but it was more
like geometric shapes or
well it's more to subscribing
it was a curved curved geometric shape
sir my tension triangles and circles
what
they're solid
is it possible you might have mistaken
it for washing Japanese any other
language
anything like hieroglyphics well in my
first impression was this is Egyptian
hieroglyphics but I knew no at that time
nobody was because now rubik's usually
have some anima simple symbols and also
activity
and the the lettering or who can call
lettering of these fabulous individual
Souls enough we're not connected were
they were in color yeah yes but they
were on a surface that was what well the
surface was the same color as the rest
$90 tally great
so it's just the symbols that we're kind
of purple pink that's right there is a
color that culture on here in all this
massive of metallic gray pieces they're
here to flash of color what do you
recall your father saying that night
about how he came into possession listen
to me
I don't recall a whole lot of the
mechanics of logistics involved you know
even go on for quite a while I'm not
sure exactly how long he did guilty but
he I remember saying something about
this came from cry cider Cooper Gold's
rancher northwest
and you said that down said that he
appeared to be excited
well it's really gossip oh why why was
he excited about this because he felt
asleep very unusual belt it was probably
something we've never seen before with
ever see again and again I want to say
that he said the words flying songs but
I cannot be sure I would most positive
if I can track all verbatim
when you said that your father had been
gone for some time or you d be hours or
days or well again you know my memories
can
he's about how old he was going I know
it's good maybe more than 12 hours maybe
a day or so and how long was he at your
home that night with the material on
floor the total time there was about 15
or 20 minutes and what happened after
that look back in the court
do you know where he went players went
back to the base such my understanding
when did you next see him to recall
I think it was the next day although I'm
not actually sure about that and did you
have a conversation with them about what
it transpired since she would see me
last well you know you can their goals
conversations up
I don't know that we talked about very
much afterwards and the initial
excitement had worn off and then in the
whole view account was put to rest
they're still feeling like they're
something very unusual about this it was
not you know
selling a commonplace like they were
like say whether one array or to her
father didn't think it was a weather
balloon or ring our target never did do
you think it was well even at that young
age I had kind of an interest in
electronics and whether they had seen
web blooms and that's in pictures and
radar targets it was not for them it
wasn't like anything you've ever seen
for not really one thing excessive park
porch was there jiving with the symbols
did your father ever speculate about
what it was where it came from we could
talk about it very I fear over the next
several years and we'd always felt it
was something very unusual I think
initially they mighta thought it was
even a Russian weapon or some head cover
for the priesthood cover-up for the
varying a story but later it was really
was not a Russian so that left one
possibility something from out of our
atmosphere was your father in the habit
of discussing this work he was in
intelligence no here's what I don't have
a discussing his work
so I guess it wouldn't be real unusual
for him to be rather quiet impenetrable
here's not given to you know rural
battery about things but he obviously
did eventually talk as time went on you
know the seed of the plant in the back
of our minds there's something very
unusual about this in time time you've
read about some UFO sighting and the
paper and trigger able conversation
about this world knowing your father is
dead
what do you think motivated him to go
public with this account yes that's he
did well it's didn't happen for years
and he was a Radiometer
love Cambria and I don't know the exact
scenario but I can picture that maybe
they're talking on ham radios he was
talking ham radio somebody and maybe the
discussion came up about a recent UFO
say and he would say oh by the way I was
involved and I could picture that as
being the mechanism that the saint came
I don't really sure but that's I think
most likely way and when journalists
people came to asking to be interviewed
for this he did he do you think he had
any were luck to you know if he had any
reluctance about speaking more publicly
to wider audience events
well this is many years later and it
most tracker a touch with in air force
community I think about any uniqueness
had worn off a bit where he felt less
constrained
Kevin I don't have any more questions
anything we failed to cover it's
important when your dad came home did he
ever suggest we weren't supposed to talk
about it is there any kind of discussion
about what was said at the base and
let's not talk about this anymore
in this for a few days I don't recall
that exactly but I think the implication
is there that it's over with don't say
anymore at least 13 grand
did after he came out with the story 78
was there ever any contact with anyone
in Pentagon or anybody from the military
suggesting that maybe he had spoken out
of turn no going back the first
statement to I never discussed this with
my friends later
our friends and acquaintances in Roswell
a conditional celery Tolo problems later
on you'd suggested that it was in high
school before he really ever discussed
it again your dad did you ever discuss
it within your friends in high school
when the storm come out in the
newspapers or suggest to anybody well
these things are real I don't recall
ever saying earlier about when you'd see
these stories in the newspapers kind of
what would you propose your reaction to
which is kind of I know something more
about ever well my initial reaction is
may grow station hoaxes and maybe a
misidentification of things but I do
know one that was not motorist
identification was it the feeling of you
your father your mother that it was
actually trust Irwin origin yeah we felt
it was all a very unique experience that
you know we just had to be at the right
place at the right time to
but what you're feeling is actually
trust yes actually my own personal
thoughts was the actor started sending
satellites around yelled and aggressions
of 1957 at the Sputnik got not built but
maybe this was a probe that happened to
land on our planet it sounds like some
who know the planet
when you had the debris in the kitchen
was there any odor associated with any
of the great ology from the call
did the material feel cold to the touch
at all well is a hot night so it didn't
you know sure is the ambient air
temperature whatever that was
is there any possibility that your dad
might have slipped a piece out of the
box to keep trade souvenir culturally
he'd never think of doing something like
that
his his background was intelligence was
that his job all through his military
career was he always an intelligence
well that in photo analysis
interpretation now did there have been
stories that he flew as a gunner well as
they
he did man the guns that I think what
happened he is a navigator or
he went aloft many times to to view the
bombing runs personally despite the fact
they had photographs but he'd get more
information about being there on the
site and I do know one time that they
were shot very badly had to take over to
us no not a man 50 calibers
he described singer boxer an empty box
mammal Harrington slugs door between his
legs through a box from a Japanese at
the Clarion and was quite excited about
that interaction and no time they were
they were shot down they had two of the
engines for engine shot out playing a
beat when I just reply very well to and
the third one gave up they're going to
like
didn't bailout Italy available so his
military career he was basically an
intelligence mostly first intelligent
fighters military career and he would
get stuck down as a as a pilot as much
as a good not ready David we know how
that worked out there are many stories
about his his military career he did not
stay for the full twenty norwegia then
he got out as a lieutenant colonel Oh
major he was given a reserve Commission
in particular but he was an active duty
ask me because I never served as a
lieutenant colonel never served as a
little anchor I know a lot of reserve
papers you got to was addressed to
Lieutenant Colonel Jesse Marcel but he
never had the privilege we took her so
he got out he had no military pension go
he got out service went back to Houma
Louisiana
was a TV radio repairman or one onda
generator television it was a little
service that's what he did until they
retired
and the first time you remember him
really talking about this you were in
high school said something while you
were in high school well about that time
frame you know because that at that era
you know flying saucers were in the rage
no you worry about these reports in the
papers the sensational magazines
the greatest story
as if we need that that sort of thing
but he was for the most part pretty
close looked about this even after he
was out of the military right it was not
really a very topic and there was no
military pension for him to protect or
no threat of only thing he had for
military was he fell off a roof
repairing his and radio antenna in
Bromsgrove
and he had a fracture of the or of elbow
and I think he had $14 you know for a
disability there was very minor
disability in the house that was the
only thing we got so that there was no
threat they could hold over him that if
you talked about this we're going to
take a look at enchirito much of that
yeah I do you remember how long how much
time he spent on active duty health how
many years he got in well no he left in
1942
and stay to 1949
so seven or eight years at all
and there was the story that's been
published that he wrote the speech for
her crewmen when the atomic bomb was
exploded by the Soviets any truth to
that or he provided the intelligence
information for the president I have a
vague recollection of something that
nature but I don't know that he wrote
the speech but I do know that he
was in preparing something
gathering information as part of this
intelligence all right but that was not
really a subject of conversation did you
ever notice your dad or did your dad
ever break security other than this one
time when he brought the material home
although he really wasn't breaking
security since wasn't classified yet
did your dad ever break security at all
if you recall one of the times
and that would be when
I don't know I guess I had to bring that
up
so as far as you know your dad really
never broke security right he never
really talked to the neighbors you never
talk to friends about what he was
learning with the job it was all pretty
okay jazz thank you very much
I'm just going to ask you some questions
just to get you started okay
Vern tell me about your relationship
with Barney Barnett
how did have you know Barney at first
met mr. Burnett I was with three hundred
and thirty-third Bomb Group down our
taxes at that time mr. Burnett was
living in the spirit of Mexico I met him
in late 1943 was on a bond write for
this component commander hood down hard
Texas they both were in the service
together
oh we were not under suppose together he
was a civilian working with civil as a
civil engineering the state of New
Mexico and what kind of relationship did
the two of you had while Barney didn't
have any children he'd raised Denise he
sort of took me under his and during the
visit he treated me at just about
Nyquist and so pretty close relationship
real close relationship I'm standing
around 1950 he told you a story about
something that had happened some time
previous can you relate that story - yes
Mr Burnett told me that and when he was
on coming back and I'm one of his field
trips he'd run out to a flying saucer
that had burst open and there were four
beings on the ground that he was
surveying this net about the time
archaeological group from the University
of Pennsylvania comes there about four
or five people with this group as they
were just starting to work things over
really closely military moved in and
give them a briefing to not say anything
about it and to keep quiet net was in
the national interest to get out of
there
what what was his feeling about what it
was that he had experienced he had no no
qualms about what it was he said the
vehicle on our space any question the
beings under were nothing like not
exactly like human beings country
similar but not exactly how did he
describe he described them being about
three and a half to four feet tall very
slim and signature and whether their
heads were hairless but no eyebrows no
eyelashes no hair and sort of a
parachute dead with cotton head being
smothered her larger any other
characteristics about their appearance
only one thing any mentions because the
hands were not covered they had four
fingers
how were they dressed they were dressed
in some type of a tight-fitting suit it
looked like my sort of a metallic but
not metal and not lanolin their grille
had fit to the body very closely tight
they were not wearing any head pieces no
I don't recall these and anything about
what the header
were all of these beings dead when he
found them they were all dead than only
a short distance from the ground crafted
burst open and they didn't he said that
they hadn't seen anybody instead but
they really had met a chance one these
are all outs and the craft he could
quite close to the for them not too many
feet did how did he describe the craft
typical for instance a disc shaped disc
shaped and a pretty good size not small
it was crafted Brooker I carried quite a
few beings that wasn't one a little
small discs at three quarters of
thickness great hundred feet big what
did he how did he describe the impact
site if at all he said it had come to
rest as sort of an ax not a high bank
there sort of a richer her banking had
hit against Bank had split there but it
otherwise it was intact it did he
describe any other degree or wreckage
besides there was no regarding to him
there was no wreckage or debris or
understood but what did he give any
description about the archaeology team
nothing except doors four or five people
they were obviously they're from dig and
they had
just kind of kind of upon us just about
nearly simultaneous he just arrived her
and here they any aims of any reason
business he didn't have any names
because the short period that they were
there and by the time the army run him
up and told him to get out of there
after he briefed what not to stand Sun
he got into becoming headed back from
her in his office did he ever tell this
story to anybody else he went back to
his office in his bus he started to town
and the boss told him Bonnie won't tell
me anything about it they won't hear
about it just forget it he says when I
was told that he's had having told have
been told not to say anything he said
and I don't have people thinking of
crazies I never told anybody else until
you tell me who told me about
did he ever experience any form of
harassment from the government they were
harassing him on income taxes I know
that at one time I VISTA down here in
1915 he was really nervous this was
either the second or third time they had
audited him
I can't understand why they would out of
him because he only he didn't do any out
a business here they had it always
income from his general what kind of man
was Barney Barney Barney Burnett was a
real private individual he didn't smoke
he didn't drink his family and himself
for very private he associated people
but not too much on a social basis but
he was very reliable professional man
lived a lot in the out of doors and knew
the outdoors collected arrowheads he and
I went on air head has gone on pottery
he digs herself he showed me how to
rouse Britain how their structures
Smita will on a time together because
way out there New Mexico near governor
there's miles and miles and miles
there's nothing so with a lot of time to
talk and all the time I knew by he never
told me a story I was never told any
story of anything about anything so I
believe anything that he would say was
reliable I could have had a lot more
information but I didn't pop in for
information at that time I was raising a
family and busy in the military and the
team things to do and it could have got
a lot more information
but
was one of those things you think bank
we hadn't had anybody in outer space we
hadn't had anybody in the world if it
had been we had progressed this thing I
might have been a little bit more
interest in the details when he when he
related this account wouldn't what did
you think about the story I had no
doubts about knowing his reliability I
had no doubts but it was real and of
course he said that he was spurned to
secrecy I was still in the Air Force so
I didn't go around blabbing this to
everybody afternoon
I had no reason to really bring it up to
anybody first time was brought up is one
when the doctor friedenberg was in
Bemidji
he gave an electron UFOs had gone and I
listened to this I thought you know
I wonder if I should relate this to him
they're doing this to Venus might be
important to his titties
so as a matter of fact I thought about
it and then I left the out of turn it
was cold out it was playful I think I
walked about a half a bar from her not
saying that well maybe it's a good
policy that back gentlemen
you know I didn't feel comfortable not
doing so then I walked back and talked
to him and a few days later that's mr.
Moore was nearing he came over my house
and interviewed me about the details I
had have you experienced any
repercussions from having shared this
not what has anybody harassed me
everybody that wants to unstableness
trees had nothing but good comments most
people believe these actually exist and
don't really believe that had one batch
or ever they intentionally didn't give
your address but I had calls from every
play every position except Easter notes
from Florida Texas and the amount of
people have seen this I was amazed
you don't have any regrets about having
divorced has no regrets about it as a
matter of fact it can tell us em story
though sometimes without changing it
because and not to be actually I'm not
about to alter anything I wouldn't
accept one penny or one damn to make any
statement because that would ruin the
validity what mr. Barnett didn't respect
him I wouldn't do it as the former
military man what do you think our
government should do now that this story
is out I can't see any reason why
whatever information you have is not
released I think any information for
documents should be released because
most of the public believes they exist
to me huh and I think the population now
is better prepared to accept this then
they would have been in 1947 right after
World War two but probably reasons why
they didn't want it released I can't see
any reason for not release
anything that we've not covered that you
want to talk about
the only time that I had any occasion to
possibly see thanks answer in 1940 bit
with 19 for the salmon pounder 11 pounds
per we move off the coast because the
problems with an eminent war so we moved
in Islamic city and were working out of
the Municipal Airport out there and just
tomato is between 12:00 and 1:00 o'clock
there was a district object had come
over Salt Lake City had come from the
east over the Wasatch Mountains in the
daytime it looked like the moon does if
you see in the data there was two pilots
and I knew how to I can't recall their
names and my snow filter and we run for
b-17 we immediately started didn't run a
prep protection other rooms taxi ran out
the runway took off and we chased us I
mean there was no hope it was just
distances and it could not possibly been
another airplane or balloon because the
b-17 was about the thing as it wasn't a
market tent it come over from East right
directly over the airfield and then it
went west when we took on then it just
about went at a for a real steep angle
going to the northwest went up they kept
getting smaller and smaller till it was
just just like a little bow hunter
nothing that I know of could possibly
climb at least that's what we hear 1940
and because one overseas in 1941 was in
Hawaii first December 1940
I was quite familiar with airplanes that
always had an interest in aviation and
that's coming into the air so I have an
idea what they were doing good racking
as the difference between something like
thank you very much I appreciate
well hope works good business it's
basically what they were pretty very
hankering you know trying to reconstruct
and they did film about 20 30 40 minutes
but they want to use portion and they
freaking stressed
did you read you a sentence by the end
of the dramatization or pretty much but
there was some details that would have
changed and of course was impossible for
them to know every detail if I had been
on their state I could have told him
such in Jersey like memory wearing a
pith helmet yeah wearing the pith helmet
well in another thing he had classes
because that when he opened the snakes
not in the venom of horrors passes
that's how I vividly remember that I
could picture in my mind the venom still
streaming down his face not his glasses
they did two glasses Muslim we just have
a white former Denali
good thinking work license I guess huh
but this type individual he was an
endorsement
he knew the Southwest he knew the
outdoors and he was the type of
individual that didn't exaggerate on
anything we did a lot of things
I know that New Mexico began Anna would
have vast uninhabited area that place is
that's why the group from New Mexico
scan left lots of the things I was the
move because they know it was probably
know exactly but I had been through a
good portion in that would day I lived
in Clayton New Mexico 110
are you living at Butchie uh-huh still
still in Bemidji
I put in 21 years the United States Air
Force retired from them put in 30 years
with a v8 just about 30 years I like
brie and I'm interested when I visit
foreign countries interpretation to see
everything industries but the people are
doing clinical living you know I'm not
wanting to content it just to sit back
and go lameness in order to go to the
beach whatever just like to then imagine
you think I'm interesting on in the
world and out of this world to obviously
from can I ask you to just sign this
form for me ended well the officers all
left
wait we have some minor man this Porter
what were you doing in Roswell New
Mexico in July of 1947
I was flanked remember have the Army Air
Base packed and what was your rank of
Master surgeon and what would normally
be your duties as a flight crewman
that's flight engineer engineer and what
sort of normal activities would you
engage well it took care of the engines
in flight and weight and balance and
field management and you log in a lot of
hours and doing that effect but what
crafted using flies it's a big up
exclusively yeah then all right
oh I understand that something rather
unusual happened in July of 1947 at the
base you were involved in a flood what
what happened that day did you recall
how they refer the these pieces that
toast it was a part of the blank saucer
and foot and Rozell forward
we started out this total beat going to
wright-patterson
and we got Fort Worth and they transfer
to pay 25
in Turkmen to wright-patterson
and what did you do then then we return
okay who who do you recall was on board
that b-29 when he left Roswell Colonel
Jennings was on board and and Colonel
Baron saw nature
wonderific and
major Marcel the ones up front and and
who wasn't told you that these these
four pieces of flying zone ruin for
distant but it was but it must have been
captain Houston
Oh what did you think when you heard
that well the West first I've heard if
not your flying saucer so didn't really
mean all God looked up what was it that
was actually loaded on board that you
saw when we had the edges packages and
wrapping paper and one of them was
triangle-shaped about two and a half
feet across bottom
and the rest were in smaller packages
about the shoebox
the triangle shape is that an unusual
kind of package it seemed to be and and
this was a brown paper on the outside
with tape and do you have if you
actually load this stuff what what was
your feeling when you just like picked
up an empty package is that right very
light from from feeling the package did
you have a sense of what it was that was
underneath the brown paper wrapper not
really just just brown paper on tape but
very light and approximately how much of
this stuff did you bring onto the b-29
was the one triangle shape packaging
about three shoebox-sized marriages so
wasn't it not very much if on if we were
to can you give me an idea that with the
volume of all this would be well it's
and you put it in the say a backseat of
a car or a trunk of a car yes it's just
small packages and
took a b-29 that wasn't necessary to
take the violence that was
transportation that's all you had right
and what would the fellas talk about on
the way to - there wasn't much talk I
but they didn't talk for very much
yeah with that would that be unusual was
there normally a lot of conversation
around tween is watch learn irregular
crews how was that why do you say no we
had officers from other squadrons in
the colonel Jennings was the deputy base
commander
major Marcel's
would be unusual for them to be like yes
and you arrived in Fort Worth at
Carswell right and look to what were
your what happened then
well we parked on the front lying flat
lane and Colonel Jennings to us to
finish we had some Sparkletts to change
and he said the Senate we got our
maintenance down and Gardens posted we
go eat lunch and come back
was there anything unusual about your
arrival at Footwear I know so you did
your maintenance then you went out to
lunch and what happened after you got
that we came back and they moved the
aircraft to the back flat
toes that transfer the material to be 25
to go into wright-patterson and that it
was the weather that was there what did
you think when you heard that well I
just thought this but it was accepted
with your head and then you flew back to
Roswell right was there any conversation
on the way back the mountains how about
after after this episode was there
anymore hat was it something that just
wasn't talked about it did you feel that
what we just eyes whether between o
matters and that was it did you have did
you have when did when did you first
share or when were you asked about your
involvement in this act in 1979 Stanford
and what did you did you learn anything
more about this than you had known
before that not does it surprise you to
know that Jesse Marcel at least said
that it was not a weather balloon well
not really
I never thought much
after all these years what do you think
it was it wasn't a weather book you're
pretty sure that that's because of what
people say yes ma'am you're you're out
of the service is for wild mountains 26
27 years again
are you are you getting a pension yes
have you gotten any kind of harassment
or anything not from having talked about
this do you have any regrets about
having talked moon no what do you think
the government should do now about all
this well I think they should love to
people
you'd like to the ointments yes
is there anything we haven't talked
about that you'd like to say it was
putting no loans we've done it all
straight
well mr. Porter cannot a little bit
about yourself were you living now and
what's been your profession over the
past few years well at present I and my
wife reside in Southern California in a
small community called Spring Valley in
the neighborhood of San Diego I think
for our purposes is close enough
and I practice as a dentist in that
region
about 1952 after my
there is some active duty after
following Korean police action because
correctly
I met Debbie Henderson in the early mid
60's the best of my recollection maybe
1962 or 63 how would you happen to meet
him or about him well I was introduced
to him by a mutual friend
we were of course one of my other
vocations other ministry has been
practicing of studying metallurgy
I think that probably what got Patti and
I together and as years went along my
two other ventures I wound up actually
joining one of his because it really
proved to be interesting I described it
fully in our meeting today
I don't know
what else to say we've gained a great
deal respect for each other
I trusted his judgment as he did mine I
guess
was a very nice relationship and when
did he tell you about something that
occurred was very unusual in 1947 well
it was nearest I am able to tell it
would would have been and I think it
might have been the perhaps the 30th
anniversary of that event because it was
right about that time of the cinema
summer of 1978 and what was it that he
related to years as to what what had
occurred well in he of course we will
understand we were in a public place
where we met frequently
but we did speaking in quite a great
deal of privacy let's say
he told me about the Roswell incident
when that incident occurred why I happen
to have been in a period of in active
duty in my naval service and I was
living in northern Minnesota I guess the
the wire service never reached me
I was actually unaware of the Roswell
incident that was casually mentioned in
my newspapers perhaps as late as a month
later when I was
but northern Minnesotans were too
worried about it it makes it
see so what did Pamela Anderson tell you
happen but he said that he had unusual
job performance his Air Force service
they transported wreckage and
buddies of the alien people to file that
simple
Jack was a man a few words really
in our habit the way we dealt talk with
each other we really didn't waste much
time
we said it and that's that nothing more
to it did he describe any of the
wreckage to you not really at that time
it was just a smashed
firewood I guess base breakage
spacecraft garbage and the I guess some
of the passengers there on suffered
their death of course
I really was more or less privileged to
just be listening so I refrained from
asking a lot of questions but he did say
that these people were small
and that
there were quite a number of them he
never described the actual number to me
since I first have been filled in
somewhat I'm still not sure that there
were what they even claim now
did he describe their appearance any
further than saying they were small not
to me
I think he found the kind of distasteful
I was pretty well tuned in the text
feelings you know
if something was bothering I'd be aware
of it
very soon
you know what kind of crafting flew to
wright-patterson well as the Navy man I
wasn't too familiar with what the Army
Air Corps later Air Force yeah
my experience with airplanes in
tailor
craft of papers and Arrakis advanced
things like that pre-world War two
things that I flew the rest of it
nice but I it was one of the B's b-29
perhaps
did he did he say what is takeoff point
pause well I assumed it was risible he
did not say to me where it was from but
that he did he did say that he was going
to write Paris government that's where
he did say he said that the
remains there and
he said very likely in the frozen state
which would lead me to believe that that
being the case that autopsy work was
being planned
undoubtedly
did he related following this flight
that would shed some light on what the
wreckage or the bodies were all know it
was perhaps a year later we were meeting
again under about same circumstances but
he said have a game of gula and
a little break in our game why produce
this piece of metal for me to
this is what what I think of it well
it's different
I felt it in that field and I studied in
some was able to determine that it's a
metal structure was different than
alloys like we have in our aircraft
presence and of course he did
Trevis
question by stating this was from this
craft
I think it was a case of
appropriation that he acquired this you
know for future study perhaps
any rate I give
thorough looking at
to say that
it was a lie that
we are not used to we have
we don't think we do
there is a possibility we may be come up
with something like it
what do you feel very big roundabout
statement I understand how about
describing it for me what did it look
like feel like well it was a lustrous
gray lustrous metal and resembled
aluminum it was lighter in weight and
much stiffer if you're familiar with
aluminum alloys like ste what 37 is a
very stiff tough aluminum well this was
harder and stiffer than that could you
bend it no
and I did want to try the edges were
pretty sharp
and jacket
let it out of his personal
ownership so
I couldn't take it into my 11 and
there's some testing on it which I
really would like to
number one I'd like to upon a
what it would take to machine
machinist language - milord
that decision came
is Oliver having made an alloy similar
to it which
up to this point no one's been able to
scratch it so to speak but that's kind
of beside the point
I think this is one other reason that
Jack showed me this piece because our
association had gone on quite a few
years and he trusted me
and I didn't tell anyway
I think this is my first discussion
as this thing publicly
what did he do with this with this piece
of metal he put it in his pocket and
that's the last I've seen of it
it's probably in his personal effects
his wife states that
there's many boxes of his things
that she has gone through opener
birthday
could be could be that that piece is
there and I certainly recognize it if it
were
my feeling was that the metal itself was
not
a crystal
lattice structure like alloys that we
make it was more of an amorphous
and
the fractures of the edges were marked
like fractures rather than tears
so I recall a they had a colloidal
appearance like plate glass bottle
Lazarus's would had to break it smooth
concave shapes it's real sharp edges
what's significant about that well that
indicates that it's not crystalline
which may have a lot to do with its
physical properties who have some flight
or resistance to to heat
the entrance takes a
I know we're using nonmetallic materials
like
was scared
corner
shuttles with so
to observe this apparently didn't need
what what year is with your background
your knowledge of metallurgy would you
think this was something that would have
been easily manufactured using
technology available at the time you saw
this material well I don't think it's
been easy for us to know
I think we're looking at pretty high
temperatures and smelling one thing I
think now perhaps through the Bajor
they have refractories for instance of
change in furnaces or smelters they
they're able to tolerate better
different higher temperatures
then we have more let's say more
sophisticated temperature control things
of that nature that would be needed to
perfect an alloy like and I do think
that it hit the metal I think that
should be used with the quotation marks
metal is is a salacious a line
what does that mean to the lane well
that it's a compound
silica
with whatever the main constituent met
itself be
we found some in the United States
Tomic wait which appears to be somewhere
very close to iridium
in fact that causes a several problem
presses a lab techs reading the plates
because of the overlay of the lines
spectra lines
there's one material that was was I
would
but made witch
proved to be
a similar
it's one we made ourselves
but with a lot more
what is your own belief about what this
fragment was from
well I think it was a one of the
structural parts not they the thinner
materials
I know that Jack himself I stated to me
up as far as the thin material school
that that was the lining of the craft
that when properly energized it produce
the perfect illumination inside
that you had to easy light with no
shadows
but it's why I asked today this
gentleman that
because Jesse that had his hands on some
of that thin material if he had seen it
in the dark because he had read bidding
testitude he's pretty young and anyway
what that would be kind of interesting
to see if it could be energized
or polarized maybe as would need to be
it's hard to say I think a little take a
good but all scientists and maybe one of
our businesses friends could tackle and
light the place up with a piece of that
you know
it's barely possible
what do you think this was from I mean
what what was this is Dan who has
recovered you know I think that metal
let then material was different I didn't
see any of it from what I've seen of the
pictures and so on I I don't think
that's the same the same metal is that
maybe you're feeling that this was from
an extraterrestrial spacecraft oh yes or
there's no question my mind about that
the one craft that crashed in the saves
and was just split open a color of it
the way it looked and photos
about the way that pieces I have to look
at
I'm sorry which photo are we talking
about here well whether it was a drawing
or a painting or a reconstruction I
don't really know but it was here today
that's more or less what it looked like
a slightly mistreated maybe that didn't
look I'm at my temperatures now come
down on your mind though this was from
outer space I have no question but was
from outer space the bodies
the reason we don't have a franchise on
universal yeah I you're interested in by
thinking on that matter why
I don't think we have a franchise on
being the only good guys and or bad guys
either that matter in the universe
obviously this was something that was
considered to be highly secret Pappy
Anderson one would have shared this with
you right without foundation of trust
right well he has been to serve the
protocol
not mention it was a I did I was kind of
surprised to find it he'd taken a couple
other people and his confidence
one of which was billed
also there is another one that we
discovered
this is a naval helicopter pilots who's
retired now
this aware of yep yet see
it was pretty choosy about we talked to
it did he express any any feelings about
this secrecy aspect or why it was that
he wanted to share this information
websites could become ill with death no
carcinoma
I would guess that he probably wanted to
leave it I had Nick bill walls breaks
but expressed that notion
he went to leave it just in case he did
which is worked out he did
oh he had great hopes that he would be
given be given up a ride and it would
probably would have occurred by now
seemed like he had sort of set up in
someone
it's beyond my knowledge of his activity
but should only take big cases
Switzerland you
and wedding arrivals there fact all the
puddings it was made
those spaceman and which incidentally
I've seen that but some of them on that
greatly resembles the channel 13 that's
the right channel in LA
that photographed the two that flew over
just
see there
an anti-war orange too
they they just came in and made us
moving in and out and someone just
happened to be taking some pictures
Senate and that
films proved to be
and those look for all the world exactly
like one since
you know Pappy made a great effort to
apprise me of what all that's listening
he spent quite a bit of money on books
for me into that name
some of which involved some of our own
military where they were doing
intensive study to verify the
authenticity of these Swit
landings
and they
I think to a man on these bounds
conclude that they were real and they
all a schoolchildren there
I've seen pictures and movies of both
people
you can't have 38 kits I'll give you the
same story usually on anything but on
this one issue boy there was no question
about plus the description of the
squadron commander in that case was a
lady and she first button was three and
she
described her craft allowed him to
photograph as far as this metal
fragments concerned do you have any idea
where it is now today no I don't I think
if it's anywhere it be in his personal
effects
it was pretty traumatic when Jack died
at that time
her daughter's mother-in-law was in a
very ill and so they just packed sample
up out of her apartment moved her to LA
to help take care of the soul lady
and I think yes Apple said if it's
anywhere it's in some of the old boxes
they haven't even opened yet so I'm
going to look at
see like maybe condenser Leroy
very much like to know
well fine I get it it will get right
straight for my safety deposit box and
then I'll get on the telephone and I
won't tell him which bank it said not
that dick in that well thank you doctor
you're very welcome
I'm hopeful that strengthen your
thinking in some ways I've been
eliminated
a lie what by finding that metal out
I'll send it back here and I should know
I think there was one gentleman
somebody on our board called David
Schwartzman I bet you yeah yeah was a
white artist at Howard University yeah
yeah okay
that thought he'd be the one that he
seemed to be most interested in that
piece of metal and also on the smelling
techniques that were developed they know
about that stuff yeah well he really got
a kick out of what I told him about her
misfiring trying to cut that
chimes happens numbers I mean Stanford
University and
one of our government facilities I think
has a unit there this button it was made
for cutting and analysis well he
couldn't
I sent it back there a few scratches and
said they broke every
mentally they had
he gave up now this was a of what tested
before we think it's the similar one I
was why Jack got me involved
oh yeah that's that's really it goes way
how do you hear about this tested
standard well I know what I sent it to
him oh I'm into it that part
see you got this piece of metal or
something yeah I am boom the button that
went to stand for I had made it oh oh
okay this is this is a fabricated saying
not okay I'll make sure I understand
that okay dr. Carter can I get you to
sign that for me sure
you've read first
are you nuts
jealous networks $5 e well one of the
things she wanted me to put together
this volunteer slide program and have
some kind of a cut out of this little
angel yeah that works
are you alright when those first Erica
and she wanted all of the slides of all
the volunteers from every sad thing to
be shown through this little image of
this ok just let that go for nothing
don't feel like there's no way that I
like time to shoot in such a format so
that the picture of the person's face is
showing through the exact center of the
fly there's no way that I can't
manipulate the size of the slides to
make the image appear within the body of
his angel and network yeah yeah up real
close nobody pushed the whole book about
a quarter of an inch to your right this
one yeah we go right there boom that's
perfect right there
ready rolling
Wow oh that's cool
do one worth him I'll let me get a
better taping that but you know once you
go wide and then Xun know that each
other okay go back where he started my
call soon as you go okay ready go hey
guys yeah too too far ahead but that's
you got the right concept okay okay
ready here we go okay here it comes
yes yeah because you can pick up you can
pick it up at any point while the pages
are writing like it goes off until we
really just do it I think I can nail a
little better
Oh too far the first time I'm not
throwing up that time go get ready
rolling roll I can't here we go Sarah
comes here comes it's coming yeah good
that's the best type of let it roll let
it roll I'll do one more time just okay
yeah it comes oh yeah we got it
I think got in the last okay good tell
me just what settles down it moves that
much aside it in the name
try it slow that was a good one right
there try it one more time slow
hold it hold it I wonder one more
hold it
good so what would it be something more
to do we wanted to do the books American
separated from international don't get a
figure you're wearing okay that's okay
yes
Afton hit yeah okay I can be tighter
everything yeah so it's just like they
have to read and that last one should go
on top the paperback book look like that
should be the last one you throw down
because it has UFO the one what's the
most happening is writing on ready yes
the commercial was right in the middle
he did what's another baby another
French magazine drawn oh yes sir
that's pretty good except there's
another French magazine maybe we don't
want to eat it it looks very much
similarly oh yeah it's very that's why
right side up the book the great one has
no me no it's not it's plate car when it
hit because most evil stand by
that's it just hold that okay
yet the
a little too fast little too fast
yeah I slowed down okay
Oh
it's uptown Scotch okay
the only thing I'd like to do I don't
want to make that one books give two
prominent mention I mean read what
happened say I don't want his name okay
therefore Scherzer yeah he'll usually
sign this books Kathleen Kevin I am
about that
oh yeah make sure we get robbed okay
it's kind of tough to get Roswell not
you now he's right there it's at a safe
area you might see it but don't know how
your Fargo you did don't worry about
necessarily neat don't worry about it I
don't necessarily need this I'd rather
at this you know what go ahead and shoot
it wide I'll just write this D p.m. and
honestly focuses name it really it's
really gonna be a big deal no no it's
not no something big that's like the
unknowable sits on the other oh there's
fine that's fine
I'll say oh really online okay what
you're talking about I see it I see you
try today we made take that book out see
you missing it I moved it up skosh so
I'm seen the previous today history yeah
history there we go like that
how much fun
this captain Randall called me on Friday
that Alliance offers business he's now
in a very Treasury this thing is just
Friday night what's Friday night one
month associates in UFO world mailed me
video just released sound rolling
the guy who was the producer Showtime
Birkhoff you call him up
I see the one yet that's a little soft
from beginning they're good
okay
I'm doing boots help I don't think you
can tell their books go wide boys we're
from fun up yet arrangement well well
yeah some names name I mean we've got
doing here discredit you know your
absolute thing its back on the back yeah
it's a wide shot probably be this wide
or a closer or relics good okay all
right here we go
so
so climb
because what I've been seeing so long
and what you're telling is you make
sense seen both sides but it's like a
game good bad good I thought it was
great
I'll just cut my finger you got my
fingers in there um yes
okay I'll just cut it off in the DPN
okay and let me shut it keep rolling and
just leave stay wide like that because
what I'll do is I'll try to get the fact
if it doesn't work then it doesn't work
but okay okay now you got this you got
this shot right okay we got we got that
shot so now we need this
okay now just zoom in on National
Geographic
okay okay and then just zoom out too
while I open it up nothing tell me all
right
all right tell me when
No
okay
those are wild looking keyboards well
one guy uses keyboards every day to find
out where the stock and currency markets
are as Donald Vandemark and he's got the
latest numbers nice very much Fred the
market is mixed today traders obviously
confused about the unemployment if we
can't support a drive will save it
homeless to come in our not having that
much luck because some people just don't
want to come in and as the mayor said on
television in quarters super competitive
rivals
Roswell Daily Record
we called a imagination
some lots of all these allies made I was
just looking for to the chicken so you
come with more [ __ ] now say first with
us the books and they're saying here now
now is this an S&S and just keep dream
this is just like the spaceship she then
every day they bring Sun moment it gets
me to tell the truth
we watched it use a lemon law
well
yeah okay it's like that's better
sors
- obsession